afternoon first of all thank you so much
for having me here
big thanks especially to Chris and Jenny
and the other organizers and staff here
at PI data Carolina's especially thanks
for hosting this content that we're
creating here together online I actually
spend about eight years in Asia and
during that time four of those years I
was getting an undergraduate degree and
online resources were incredibly
important part of that so I'm grateful
to all the content producers and to PI
data for for hosting all this great
content online so just a few quick notes
before we get started I may have tried
to pack a little bit too much into this
talk if you had a look at what we're on
what we're talking about today there's a
lot for us to get through I have gone
out of my way to try to make sure we can
have a discussion at the end for about
five minutes but so that we get there I
just ask that if you have any questions
write them down jot them down and save
them for the end or find me in the halls
or or online afterwards and I'd love to
talk to you guys about that stuff so
break the talk up into four sections
today first section is just a couple of
case studies and we're looking at these
case studies with the idea that python
gives us a toolset that allows us to
build powerful toys over a weekend and
powerful tools on the order of a few
weeks or months so we look at a few
different tools that I've built by
composing the functionality of multiple
libraries and look at kind of what goes
into that and then from there we'll talk
about some tools and strategies for
interactively exploring api's so when
you've got all these different libraries
that you're working with what are some
tools that we have available and what
are some strategies that we can use for
finding integration points and getting
these libraries that often are maybe not
immediately compatible to talk to each
other and then lastly we'll talk about
how to stand on the shoulders of giants
without falling we'll talk about some
pitfalls and difficulties that can arise
when we're taking powerful things and
we're gluing them together quickly and
then lastly
have some time for Q&A and if you guys
have some tools and strategies that you
use for these things I hope that you'll
you'll share them as well so for the
case studies the the first tool that
we'll look at is a tool that I built
called snake cam I like to give kind of
cool little names to these these little
toys that I build this one is a tool
that I use to run to find and run
functional and unit tests at work and
then I also read this book called wind
sock wind sock is just a tool for
sticking your finger in the air and
saying which way the wind is blowing on
a topic on Twitter so we'll first take a
quick look at snake cam this came from a
huge pain point that I have at work and
that's manually running unit and
functional tasks how many people use
knows to run tests okay cool
how many people run your tests from the
command line okay how many people type
out the whole name of the thing that you
want to run when you run it from the
command line okay
so you didn't raise your hand maybe at
the end you can tell me what your
strategy is for doing this cool all
right so that's difficult to read I
apologize but what we're looking at here
is so this is these are some unit tests
from pyramid pyramids a web framework
that we use for several of our micro
services at work and so you'll have a
test method a parent class that test
method belongs to and then that will
live in a module over here so what does
this look like if you want to run it
from the command line without any tools
to help you out well you type knows
tests really long module name colon
really long class name dot really long a
specific test name and you only need to
do that you know a few dozen times
before you try to find a better way to
do that for awhile for me that was some
grep and Hawk foo pipe together to nose
that was kind of brittle and didn't work
so well so I dug into the man pages and
there is a plugin that you can use to
tag each test with an ID and that felt a
little bit clunky and I'm now I've got
to track all of these
all of these tests it's not really what
I'm looking for so surely someone else
has had this problem in fact they have
157 people at least on Stack Overflow
who voted on this but this is just what
we already knew which is type the whole
thing out buried down at the very bottom
of the answers was this guy he had a
really kind of cool solution he defines
his work-in-progress decorator attaches
it to a test and then that's kind of
similar to the first one I thought that
was clever but still not exactly what
I'm looking for
so what would be ideal here I'd like to
have a test sorry a tool that I give
some tokens from the test that I'd like
to run I'd like it to find that test and
and run it I'd like to pass some options
so am I looking for a test method or a
test class or a test module and then I
just like to pass whatever options I
normally pass to knows as a
comma-separated list here and have it
run the tests and show me the output so
I built that thing and I'll just give a
quick demo I'm not going to do a live
demo just to save time but we'll try
video here and kind of go through it so
we're here in the the pyramid unit tests
we're here in this testing code module
we're looking at this test unit code
vowel multiple test that takes some
unicode strings and checks that pyramid
is gonna URL and code them as we expect
it to and so we can go over to our shell
here and invoke our tool and pass it
some tokens from the test there so
unicode battle multiple and it finds it
straightaway and runs it so the whole
goal here was to make life easier on
ourselves so it'd be nice if we could
just pass it some partial tokens so
something like yuna and val it should
still find the thing that we're looking
for it misses on the first time not done
a normalization or anything to account
for length so it's finding the shorter
test name first that's fine if we tab
through the results here the next result
that it finds the second nearest
neighbour seems like maybe there was
something else I'm forgetting to say
here there goes
and it runs uh runs those tests so now
maybe we want to run the parent class so
we can just invoke the tool again with
the C option for class URL Inc and it
finds the class and runs them and
likewise with the module the testing
code module we'll just give it the M
switch and it will do what we expect
there as well so what's involved here
well I'm using argh parse to grab the
command-line arguments I've written some
glue code to approach those arguments
set up the script and run the tests I'm
using PI copr which is really cool
actually standard library module for
doing some introspection to just to find
the method names and the class names and
the module names I've got some glue code
that will extract the test metadata from
that and then I'm using OS and pickle to
cache the data cache some timestamps for
the module files that the next time we
run this thing we're only looking at the
test files that have been modified since
the last time we checked I'm doing K
nearest neighbors with dice Sorensen I
hope I'm pronouncing the second name
correctly there looks Scandinavian not
sure about that but just a distance met
measure that that basically takes the
two times the the most common took the
common tokens between your query point
and your and one of your data points
over the total number of tokens in both
and that gives you a distance and then
you're trying to find the distance that
maximizes that value and the distance
that maximizes that value will be your
nearest neighbor and then I'm giving
giving the results of that to assist in
term color to display the results and
then I'm just spinning up a child
process to actually run the tests and
then display the test results and that's
pretty much it so that's eight imports
and about 231 lines of code we could
probably trim that down a little bit but
will be Condor so
so then we come back to maintain it and
several months we'll be able to
understand it so the next tool here is a
tool called windsock and if you read the
overview of what I was gonna be talking
about today actually said I was gonna go
through a Twitter tutorial instead of a
way to prepare for this talk and to try
to throw together a tool I've wanted for
a really long time over a weekend which
I did last weekend so you'll get to see
that today but I do do recommend you
check out the tutorial if you're
interested in this stuff this guy is a
guy from England named Marco bonds and
Nene again I hope I'm pronouncing that
right I'll put all these links together
all the links that you'll see in the
slides and then a few others and a blog
post hopefully together with any links
and tools that you have afterwards so
the tool that I wanted would be a tool
to get get data from Twitter for an
arbitrary search term processes data and
store it and then optionally for these
next two things I want to build it in
kind of a modular way so I've got some
utilities that I can use anytime but
then I've got a script directly of
scripts for analysis and a directory of
strips for visualizations I'd like to be
able to pass as options to to my tool
the names of these scripts and then for
any way any data set that I load I can
tell it you know run these analyses
scripts and then run these visualization
scripts on that data and kind of set up
a pipeline for processing this that's
modular and you can have pieces
rearranged and things like that and then
lastly you know be nice to just have the
thing spin up a web server to serve the
visualizations locally if I've run a
visualization script so I built that
thing too and we'll take a quick look at
at that quick demo of that so again I
apologize for the for the resolution
here it's poor planning on my part but
we'll invoke the tool here I gave it
Pluto as the search term I'm filtering
retweets there so only get source tweets
looking for 5,000 tweets
give it the freaks analysis script to do
some term frequency analysis and the
freaks of is visualization scripts to
visualize that and the verbose option
there as well so this thing will go off
and start gathering tweets one of the
reasons I chose Pluto is because it was
trending the other reason I chose Pluto
is because it was the least likely
have or ibly offensive stuff scrolling
across the screen here is anybody that
spending time on Twitter knows doesn't
mean there wasn't some in here but
anyway so it's going to run our
processing and visualization scripts and
then it's going to spin up a a web
server here which we can go and check
out and then you'll get to see how much
of a days designer I am not these
visualizations are not very beautiful is
kind of the out of the box thing that I
got with the library that I was using
but still pretty cool here you see that
I've we've gathered the most frequent
terms for the tweets that we got we've
got moon read Quran don't really know
what that means cat knew not really sure
what's going on here if we take a look
at the oops sorry if we scroll down we
can see the most frequent by grams it's
maybe a little bit more interesting so
right now I'm making a leap here and you
wouldn't be able to make this leap if
you didn't already know something about
the data any statisticians in here about
to get offended but it looks like you
know maybe it's talking about the Quran
is maybe a moon and there's some dust so
maybe some red dust and a red cat so red
cap and and red dust maybe connected
somehow I mean I thought this was this
was pretty cool getting this this data
and visualizing it this way so even
cooler than this actually was using a
library called Vader to do a bit of
cinnamon analysis so I did cinnamon
analysis on these terms so again not a
designer not great with visualizations
but what you're looking at here is for
all of the tweets that appeared for the
most frequent terms that we saw this is
where they fall from positive to
negative score of 1 to negative 1 in
terms of sentiment and what you should
see is fewer and fewer data points as we
go to the right because we had fewer and
fewer terms and I promise you that's
what's actually there but what's
actually happening is that for some of
these you've got quite a few retweets
that that weren't actually retweets I
mean they weren't tagged as retweet spot
Twitter but maybe they had the exact
same text and like a different URL
shorten link or something in it and so
you've got these you've got these
clusters of duplicates right on top of
each other anyway the it did pretty well
for this this one positive term here
we'll take a look at this this was the
most positive thing I could find I hope
you have an amazing birthday I love you
to Pluto and back thought that was sweet
not really about Pluto but that's pretty
cool most of the rest of the examples
that I have or cases where it didn't
necessarily get it right I thought that
was both more interesting and also helps
to drive home a point I'll make later
during the the pitfalls section of the
talk but one of the things that
struggled with with science related
tweets and with news related tweets was
things that were very neutral that had
maybe negative phrases in them that
attack is negative so here it's saying
that Pluto moon moon currents redhead
tended by trapped gas methane trapped by
the chilly winter night is slowly
something I'm guessing that because
maybe trapped
was a negative it tagged it as negative
here but for for things that maybe
should have found neutral it tended to
struggle a little bit although if you go
and you read the paper about this model
and look at what these the the people
that worked on this they accounted for
lots of edge cases and had some really
clever ways of doing that so another
place where it tended to struggle was
with sarcasm and kind of thinly veiled
insults and since it's election season
we didn't have to look very far for that
plenty of that in the search term for
Clinton here this is 15,000 data points
for searching for Clinton and so a few
places where it struggled with sarcasm
was we've got this this tweet here
thanks Clinton / Obama for giving an
Israel 38 billion instead of caring for
the middle class it's obviously not a
very positive tweet but it thought that
it was another another place where it
struggled here was everything about her
head but her head brain and memory
Clinton doctors declares her fit to
serve as president so very mean-spirited
tweet there that was flagged as as
positive
next one here
I would love to volunteer at the Clinton
campaign would like actually return my
web form submission so some some person
who wanted to volunteer and never got
called back it did much better with with
negative with overtly negative tweets
here's a couple of examples power
reveals discussed with Trump this days
for Clinton and hacked emails another
one for that same term which was Powell
here : Powell describes Donald Trump as
a national disgrace and reveals distaste
for Hillary Clinton hacked emails so if
you're wondering we were actually a very
positive community so for us everybody
is very very kind here the most negative
tweet we had was somebody saying that
they were ashamed to say that I'm using
evil MATLAB for this project on my
benchmark chunking and deflate level did
very little sorry to hear that the most
positive tweet we had I think might have
been about Sarah Birds talked yesterday
about Boca makes the creation of rich
and visually pleasing interactive
figures simple and fun I hate that I
missed that I was preparing for this
talk I'm really looking forward to
catching on YouTube I heard that it was
a really great talk so that's that's
that's windsock all right that's that's
one thing you can do with one sock I'm
not gonna go through the stuff in detail
for the sake of time and also because I
think most of us in here can go ahead
and abstract from this what's going on
right we're taking the difficult stuff
and doing it with a library and then
we're writing a little bit of glue code
to marshal data and and piece these
things together I will say if you have
time be sure to check out Vader or at
least NLT K is implementation of it to
the point of this talk it's super simple
to get started with on toy data sets I
can pull something in you literally pass
a string to a function and get get
polarity scores for sentiment analysis
also check out plotly if you haven't
already it's kind of doing four or one
of the tools which is trying to do four
visualizations what Jupiter notebooks
have done for for having an interactive
repple and then kind of a gooey
environment that you can share with
others Vincent is also very cool I
believe this project is defunct or at
least no longer maintained
now points that Altair both of these
tools Altair and Vincent provide
bindings on the d3.js so you can build
up your data structures in Python and
then have that create some JSON that III
Jas visualization can consume so this is
xx 1 imports either standard library
imports or external libraries and about
600 lines of code and it took a weekend
and I think 2 or 3 weekday nights to
kind of clean things up so it's you know
kind of a toy but a pretty powerful one
that was there was a lot of fun to build
so we're taking all these different
libraries 21 in this case and we're
piecing them together we need some tools
and strategies for for doing that
so the primary needs that we have here
are a way to get install libraries a way
to manage libraries across projects and
a way to interactively explore api's and
a way to view an effect state during
execution so these there's a few slides
here I think for most people here it's
gonna be pretty basic stuff but for our
online audience this talk does target
novices so I'm going to cover some some
basics here before we move into detail
about the tools so forgetting installing
libraries and packages you can imagine
your machine here you've got your system
Python installation you've got got a
place where you can put packages where
Python will know about it and if you you
run a program on your machine and Python
it can find those libraries and use them
and then you've got pi pi or the PI
packaged index that knows about
libraries and packages and as them there
and then you've got a package on your
machine that's job is to go out and find
packages and install them in a place
here where Python knows about them so
dope is the tool that I use for that I
think it's the tool that most people use
these days strictly for Python
dependencies and you can read about that
here if you're not familiar with it
already so let's talk quickly about
virtual environments
imagine that you're setting up a new
blog and that blog requires Django one
point
and so you install that and you run that
under system Python which has a Django
installed as a package and knows about
it your blog runs great and you're happy
but then a few months later you decide
that you want to contribute to this open
source project that you found out about
and they require Django 1.8 so now what
virtual environments give us an easy
solution to this we reserve system
Python and its packages for tools that
we use system-wide and then we've got a
virtual environment with its own Python
interpreter for our Django blog running
1.10 and we've got another virtual
environment with django 1.8 so if your
the tools that i use for this are a
virtual and virtual and wrapper but if
you're new to programming if you're new
to Python I highly recommend you check
out a tool called Conda it's here it
manages Python packages and virtual
environments it also manages
dependencies that are outside of Python
importantly so interactively exploring
api's and debugging I use the ipython
shell for that and I use pew DB as a way
to kind of view an effect state as my
program is executing so I use pu DB as
my debugger I'm partial to command-line
utilities I kind of live there spend
most of my time there I work on back-end
API so very little interface work and
what I do anyway but if you're if you're
partial to Google alternatives or if
that's that's kind of what you feel more
comfortable with of course Jupiter
notebook offers a kind of heavily
augmented ipython shell in the browser
that you can then share the share the
output of your work with others and then
PyCharm offers a very powerful GUI
debugger as well so I've got this kind
of little contrived example for us to
step through some code together
generating randomly colored outfits so
if we start with this white outfit here
that's kind of boring and we might want
to impress our our front-end designer
friends by adding some color to our
outfit so we might add something like
lights salmon
as our shirt color and pill violet-red
as our pants color and yes these are
css3 color names that your browser will
respect so if we were actually going to
do this and of course we would just have
a list of color names we take a random
index into it and job done right it's
probably two or three lines of Python
but for the sake of a contrived example
let's imagine that we couldn't do it
that way and we needed to tie some
libraries together I went out and found
some for this random color web colors
and side-by are the new libraries that
ended up time together so I kind of
intentionally started with this with
like something really absurd and I was
like I'm gonna find a way to tie some
tools together and make this happen and
and do it so random color gives us a
random value from 16 million plus
possible colors web colors knows about
and has mappings for 147 color values to
CSS color names so immediately we have
our first problem of incompatibility
here again ridiculous example but
consider the general case right where
you've got two completely different
things that need to talk to each other
and you've got to find out a bridge or a
way to make that happen so the way that
I thought we could make that happen is
to take one of these colors and find its
nearest neighbor in the in the set of
web colors that are available here and
so to do that we've got to write a bit
of glue code we've got to convert the
CSS string that we get from random color
so it gives RGB values and this kind of
string RGB parentheses and then the
integer values there that random color
gives us into a common format that both
web colors and sci-fi can consume and
then we've got to use web colors to
create an RGB value to color name
mapping so we've got some data
structures for looking up nearest
neighbour RGB values and also a data
structure of all the RGB values that
exists and web colors to instantiate rkg
k-dimensional tree with so we'll go
through this together and they have to
cut this a bit short because I want to
make sure we get time for questions and
and also pitfalls but and this is eight
minutes so we're not going to make it
but we'll go through the really
important parts here at the beginning
and then if you'd like to see the full
implementation or dig through the code
together you can find me afterwards so
it starts out like this tells us we
should wear white pants and white shirt
very boring
we're gonna try to change that so we'll
set up a virtual environment install our
tools here random color and web colors
and we will install ipython we'll open
up a Python shell and we'll pull in our
libraries here random color and web
colors and then from there we can start
exploring these API so let's look at
random color first and we get a nice
drop-down list with a tab completion
after the dot there random color looks
classy as in it's probably a class since
it's camel case so we'll if we give it a
question mark and hit enter we'll get
the doc string which this library sadly
doesn't have and definition for the unit
there and if we look at that definition
we see we don't really need much to
instantiate this in fact we don't we
don't strictly need anything so we can
just create an instance and now we can
explore that instance the same way just
dot and we get a nice little tab
completion of the properties that are on
this instance generate looks really
promising because what we'd like to do
is generate a random color so let's look
at the doc string and the signature for
that again no doc string but if we look
at the keyword parameters here it looks
like there's we can specify a format so
we've got a format of hex there and we
can look at the the source of look at
the source of generate here by using get
source from the inspect library and we
see that at the very end here it calls
the set format method which we can then
view the source of that and if we look
through this we'll see that it looks
like it takes HSV RGB hex and so now if
we call it and we pass it a format of
RGB which are the kinds of values that
we'll need for our KD tree we see that
we get one but again it's this way
with a CSS string so we'll jot that down
in our little scratch pad here for
that's that's the kind of data that
we're getting out of this library I'm
actually going to cut it short there
because we've kind of seen what we can
do with PUD B and a fast-forward through
some of the stuff here imagine we've hit
a problem now and we need to inspect our
data as it's executing this is what the
debugger looks like so you just set a
breakpoint here and then after that you
can step through your code step into
this method here if I want to see the
the variables that are in scope I can
look over here and get that data there
and then what's really powerful about
this is that from inside of PU DB you
can actually drop down into a Python
shell with all the context and the
environment that exists for your your
program as it's running so this is super
powerful now you're in I Python you've
got all your ipython tools available to
you with all the data you can review a
doc string here if you've forgotten how
something works and then the big review
sorry we didn't have time for the whole
thing yay we've got lots of different
outfits we run it a few more times we've
got a whole week worth of clothes so
really convoluted and a round rail but
way to do this but illustrative of the
point hopefully so attacked my approach
for attacking a problem is typically to
find relevant packages
you know first split your problem up
into these specific things that you need
to do to solve it find some relevant
packages that do those things and then
immediately skim through the
documentation and then look through the
Stack Overflow questions and check for
open issues on github see if there's any
gotchas that you need to be aware of or
is this thing even still maintained
especially if you've got two tools that
are known to work together make sure
there's no open issues or between the
two and then set up a virtual
environment install the packages and
then I'll bomb around on the ipython
shell kind of interactively explore the
API look through the source code look
through the doc strings and start
looking for points of integration
between the libraries that I pulled
and then I'll make a really simple proof
of concept something that I mean just
the dumbest possible quick
implementation brute-force Minimum
Viable script and well what I'm really
doing here is gathering context right
I'm familiarizing myself with the
surface of the problem and then from
that context I would step back think
about and research the problem using all
this new context I've gathered and being
mindful of some important that falls
which I'll step into next so we look at
the pitfalls this first one is is a kind
of personal problem that I think many
developers struggle with it's this idea
of the dunning-kruger imposter syndrome
cycle so who's familiar with these two
things
okay so dunning-kruger effect is kind of
a looser ease superiority self assessing
your abilities to be much much higher
than they actually are so it's kind of
thinking you're better than you actually
are
imposter syndrome is the inability to
internalize accomplishments and worry of
being exposed as a fraud so one of these
is thinking that you're much better than
you are the other is thinking that
you're maybe much worse than you are and
this comes up a lot when you build
something really cool really quickly
because you immediately think like oh
man I'm amazing I built this really cool
tool that does this cool thing but then
you realize like oh I'm actually just
taking stuff that other people wrote and
kind of jamming it together and you end
up kind of going between these two
things really funny thing here is that
mistaken self identification with one
kind of implies the other so you can
kind of end up with this weird recursive
kind of loop trying to figure out which
one you are untangling that mess maybe
gives a penetrating and liberating
insight into the ultimate nature of
things or something I don't know but
Buddha's cone or something but anyway so
you're pretty much fine unless you do
this you know from NLT kay sentiment in
court vader instantiate our sentiment
intensity analyzer you're a dumb smelly
jerk get some cinnamon scores and then
later that night at the party there'll
be that person right remember kind of
remember what it is you've accomplished
but at the same time don't dismiss it
out of hand right there's a lot of
context that you had to gather there's a
lot of background a lot of knowledge
that you had to have to kind of gather
these tools know the
wants to use and find ways to fit them
together so don't be overly boastful but
also don't dismiss your accomplishment
accomplishments next is uh the thing
you're looking for maybe right in front
of you so Stack Overflow is not a
panacea you know it's I use Stack
Overflow all the top don't get me wrong
but you know as soon as you hit a wall
don't immediately go and grab something
from there and start you know pasting it
into your code and then if it doesn't
work like I couldn't figure it out don't
be afraid of the documentation the thing
that you're looking for is probably
right there in the docs somewhere it may
just be that you haven't got the context
that you need or the the term that you
need to search for it to find that thing
so what you need to do is play with the
problem or explore the source code a
little bit more find some terms find
some some Google fodder find some
documentation search fodder and then go
back and attack your problem with some
tenacity so for me this is skim the docs
flourished explore ruthlessly to develop
context proof of concept and then go
back kind of to the beginning better
informed and and ready to kind of dig a
bit deeper so next for kick-ass is a
thing not a blueprint so this is for
kick-ass for any Archer fans its Krieger
he's kind of the mad scientist there and
for kick-ass is awesome but probably not
effective against heavy infantry and so
this is just kind of talking about being
being aware of overfit and the fact that
when you kind of throw something
together quickly even if you think it's
really modular and like oh we needed a
door it's so modular we could just move
these boxes and then we'll have a door
yes but if a tank comes through you're
probably in trouble right so you've
built this thing it's really cool but
just be you know before you start
throwing it out and meetings at the
office or you start trying to think that
you're gonna solve these really big
challenging problems with this toy that
you built just keep in mind that you've
kind of thrown something together
quickly and the likelihood that's going
to generalize for the general case is
very slim without a lot of extra effort
remember that library developers are
human also library exist is not equal to
problem solve so do not think like ah
it's a couple lines of Python all right
there's a library for that so I start on
Monday I should be done by Wednesday
might take longer than that expect a few
non-trivial setbacks and lots of bumps
in the road
apply Hostetler's law and then add time
Hostetler's law is that it's always
gonna take longer than you think it's
going to even when you apply Hostetler's
law so you know apply the law and then
at some time still won't be enough and
then finally this may be the most
important point of the talk developed
strategies for discovering blind spots
and dealing with rabbit holes there's no
magic bullet for this but with time and
experience you'll develop the heuristics
you need to not have typos like time and
experience in your talk sorry
some acoustics will emerge for finding
your blind spots if you're new just if
you need something concrete or sorry if
you're new be mindful of striking a
balance between not investigating enough
and getting stuck in a local minimum so
concretely here's what I try to do for
this is feel the overwhelming
uncertainty and apparent kind of
vastness of the problem and just be okay
with it and this is maybe the most
important thing that any of us have to
do when we start working on a problem
right because as soon as you're
comfortable with a problem that means
that you understand it and you've solved
it so we live here and we need to kind
of be comfortable with that and then
strike out explore and play and develop
the context as we discussed and and so
I've kind of got this little heuristic
if my brain key errors on any concept or
term three times that merits a note to
self and that might be a mental note if
it's something that I can I think I can
track or I might use quick add and
todoist
or jot something down on a piece of
paper that I need to look into this
later and this is this is kind of my my
strategy for not getting stuck in kind
of local problems that may be obviated
once I've solved for the the actual
problem that I'm after right and then
I'll get my dumb fast easy solution and
then at that time when I'm doing that
review that we talked about right when
I'm going back and thinking about the
problem more deeply with this additional
context that's when I'll review these
kind of little local problems also here
these things still relevant or kind of
did I sort this out by figuring out this
other bigger problem
so with that I'll say
magical world I wish you all the best
and exploring Python and finding ways to
build cool new things with this so it's
a great talk Rob I just wanted to kind
of add a little advice I use when I'm
doing that exploring phase of like
downloading downloading new packages to
try them out is you know developing a
new repository of directly directory and
one of the first things I put in there
is a requirement txt file and actually
write down the names of the packages
I've downloaded it installed and then
you can actually use that do a pip
install with Nestle and just install
everything that's in that file
absolutely well one thing I was hoping
for was to to get some suggestions for
tools or strategies or approaches that
that you guys use so if anybody has
anything that they'd like to share that
would be great I test over knows what's
up I test instead of knows okay I don't
think that nose is still under active
development and well my test is a
complete superset and you can basically
take your nose tests and just run PI
tests instead oh another question or a
suggestion but I think you will be
posting a lot of these tools you gonna
be building a list and you said if there
were some contributions it was the
mechanism to if we want to send you some
links or something yeah so there's you
can ping me on email at either of these
addresses my work address and then my
personal address there on twitter near
those would work once I am out of the
proof of concept stage with these tools
I'll hopefully be putting putting them
up on github and then you could just
submit some fpr's there but yeah feel
free to send me an email or if you just
like to kind of like take a look at some
of the code and like talk about some of
this stuff in more detail or see like
the full demo of the the example
a little toy example color outfit color
picker application you can follow me in
the halls afterwards and we can we can
look at that together any any questions
yes sorry not a question just something
that I learnt and just something that I
would like to share like so when we
depend on a lot of different libraries
one thing to notice that not all
libraries have a huge developer base
many of the libraries and particularly
the more obscure ones have just about
one or two people working on them and
you it's always a good idea to support
the developer either by adding some code
to it or by providing some monetary
support to it so you can see sometimes
there are some features that you see
that I it's in the changelog or it's in
the comments saying that this is right
now and the beta it's going to be merged
to the branch but that has been like
sitting there for so many months because
the person has simply has lost his
motivation to do that right or they're
super busy right exactly so it's always
a good idea to support the developers
open-source is a great thing and if
that's always a great one way or other
support the developer so that we can
have more and more libraries like this
absolutely is anybody is get tip stole a
thing that's something I kind of
participated in when it was first
announced in my familiar with github has
it so good tip was a way that you could
you could kind of tip open-source
developers and support them for their
projects to your point right I'm not
sure what it's called now I kind of had
forgotten about it until just now but
absolutely a great advice no I'm just
gonna see if there's any last questions
we've got maybe 30 seconds we got time
for maybe one last quick question may
has one
the name of get tip is now granted a GRA
T IPA y grata bet okay cool I was just
wondering when you're doing your quick
and dirty proof of concept do you flesh
out enough to run it under PUD be all
the time or do you use something also a
little quick and dirty like in bed for
my iPod so a lot of times what I'll do
is I'll how kind of build up I'll build
up a kind of quick and dirty method in
ipython and then just move that over to
because I I work in T monks usually so
I've usually got ipython running right
here with them and so I'll build up
something in ipython and then I can just
visually select that yank it over to
them and then maybe flush out a little
bit more and then stick in a breakpoint
and then work through it and figure DB
that's usually my workflow I did how
about you what do you usually do for
that what I'm doing the proof of
concepts and whatnot if I have something
in any kind of runnable state if I'm
just tinkering with it I'll copy paste
or whatever into a into a shell directly
but if I have something runnable and I
want to check it out and I don't feel
like setting up it uh
setting it up under some of the type of
debugger process I'll just import
ipython importing bed for my Python and
call it in bed yeah it's a from ipython
import in bed and then just call it in
bed as a function pop that you write in
a night Python shell right there your
execution oh nice okay it's probably a
PUD you need to be users under this yeah
exactly
yeah interesting all right how we should
think Rob for an awesome talk Thanks